je veux d'abord féliciter Pierre folief
lui-même et membre du Parti conservateur
du Canada il est sans doute le plus
enthousiaste quand à l'identité du
nouveau chef vous devez savoir que
Pierre c'est quelqu'un que je connais
depuis plus de 20 ans ça a été quelqu'un
que j'ai rencontré à l'époque
Ottawa ont travaillé avec les dents
politiques fédérales on était tous les
deux très jeunes il décrit son acolyte
de l'époque comme un rassembleur Éric
duem veut de nouveau collaborer avec
Pierre poillievre il souhaite même
ouvertement sa victoire à la prochaine
élection fédérale en immigration c'est
un dossier qui retient beaucoup la
tension dans l'actuel campagne
électorale plusieurs parties presque
tous les partis veulent que le Québec
rapatrie davantage de pouvoir en la
matière je pense qu'on aurait une
oreille beaucoup plus attentive du côté
conservateur que du côté des libéraux ou
des néodes j'ai jamais rencontré
Monsieur poyièvre si je t'ai lu 3
octobre je vais le rencontrer François
Legault a également félicité le nouveau
chef conservateur Dominique Anglade
aussi j'aimerais d'abord lui réitérer
qu'on a des demandes très claires par
rapport au gouvernement fédéral
notamment sur la question du respect du
respect des compétences des centres
compétences du Québec
d'autres chefs toutefois sont beaucoup
moins enthousiastes imaginez sous un
gouvernement conservateur polyèvre
comment c'est cet enjeu là ces
intérêts-là sont irré-consiliables les
projets de pipeline les sables
bitumineux les cadeaux multinationales
François logo ont évité les Québécois
les Québécoises à voter pour ce parti-là
le porte-parole solidaire sincèrement
pour attaquer son adversaire de la CAQ
les membres du Parti conservateur
on choisit le candidat du trumpisme
monsieur polliès c'est un Canadien c'est
un cigarien à voir avec ce qui se passe
au sud de nos frontières qu'est-ce que
vous attiré d'abord disons chez Monsieur
dum particulièrement premièrement son
charisme je trouve que c'est un homme
près des gens ce style dont elle parle
qui pourrait être qualifiée de populiste
est attribué aussi à Pierre poilliev son
discours comme celui d'Éric dum est très
axé sur la défense des libertés
individuelles si certains ont moins
d'affinités politiques avec lui le chef
du Parti conservateur du Québec espère
que sa victoire permettra de fouetter
ses troupes ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montmagny